[Música]
momento de la cultura en france 24 son
placer saludarles es probable que en
alguna ocasión se hayan topado con estos
clásicos de la escultura que además de
hacer referencia tienen en común una
interpretación y una firma masculinas y
por esa fisura es que la argentina paula
pons se coló y decidió darle otro
pliegue por qué no rendir culto a
maestros como miguel ángel y a la vez
cuestionar los lineamientos artísticos
con esta óptica surgió su serie clásicos
en cartón que sigue su técnica sobre
papel pero la lleva a una david cálida y
valiente que en buenos aires- pudo
apreciar nuestro corresponsal natal yo
que soy
inspirada en la clásica obra de su
admirado miguel ángel la artista paula
pons trabaja en su propia versión un
débil hecho mujer elegí cambiar el
personaje de masculino a femenino
como una reivindicación de que también
una victoriosa y guerrera podría hacer
una muy personaje busca dar digamos el
que esté contra goliat puede pelear
tranquilamente y no solamente hacer una
inspiradora en la historia del arte como
un montón de mujeres que tampoco son
conocidas el arte para esta gran
estructura pons trabaja con un esqueleto
metálico pero el resto de la obra está
resuelto con una técnica que desarrolló
hace casi diez años en la que combina
cinta papel y cartón es como una
escultura lo pienso que uno sabe que la
escultura la asocia en algo rígido o
pesado para el aire libre eterno y lo
mío está más ligado a la vida que no a
nadie es eterno tras dos semanas en las
que usó cuatro grandes rollos de cartón
corrugado y muchas cintas de papel pons
completo está david que se expuso en la
feria buenos aires directos de artista
ella quiere ahora que su obra siga dando
batalla en otros escenarios buscar algún
espacio de casa de cultura o me
encantaría el recoleta o un sitio que
tenga que ver con un museo como para que
pueda seguir exhibida y en un tiempo
junto a las otras obras de la serie
cuando encuentre nuevo hogar la david
seguir atrapando miradas sorprendidas
ese clásico que miguelángel esculpió en
mármol y que cinco siglos después
renació mujer hecha de cartón
con un papel aquí sí literario la
academia goncourt dio su propia vuelta
de tuerca al premiar a un autor joven
franco-senegalés y de editorial
independiente como cada año sepan que el
galardón es el más prestigioso de las
letras francesas pero con la memoria más
secreta de los hombres mohamed book
hastag ha hecho que el goncourt tenga
eco universal de hecho en su novela se
inspira de un escritor maliense real
para dirigir su protagonista otro autor
se trata de escritura dentro de
escritura que haya un libro mítico y se
pone a investigar qué fue de su creador
que ahí donde es gracia por acusaciones
de plagio esta historia se da a 100 años
del primer concurso a un autor del
continente y tiene guiños a argentina y
bolaño
es usual os premia áfrica subshariana
para que yo sea el primer africano
subsahariano en ganar el premio con kurt
puede parecer algo excepcional
excepcional el ideal célebres y de modo
que está en los swat plus pero lo ideal
sería que dejara de serlo y que en
algunos años veamos completamente normal
que un escritor africano se lleve el
galardón unido al estreno de eternas nos
gustaría no perder el hilo sobre la
diversidad de la que habla bazar y es si
realmente hace falta remarcar cada
primera inclusión es necesario para
concienciar el dilema no es baladí ante
la primera película marvel que hace de
la representación su fortaleza aunque sí
tiene distintos acentos incluso señas
aborda la salud mental o contiene un
beso homosexual se debe también a los
variados que son estos eternos que al
fin son superhéroes reconocibles por eso
se dice que esta cinta número 26 del
universo es diferente no no es por esta
familia que protege de los desde antes
sino por su paradoja de contener
demasiado explicación y que sobre
metraje asimismo puede no llegar a
gustar la dirección de la oscarizada
cruise ao esencial en entender la
mitología de los personajes que en los
70 concibió el maestro jack kirby pero
tal vez por onírica y paisajista no va a
calar tanto en muchos fans acostumbrados
a que la fantasía venza al realismo una
fantasía que aquí traza toda la historia
de la humanidad en un único filme
venir los insectos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
en georgetown
en otras noticias no dejamos escapar que
en cuba así como paula pons también hay
un grupo de artistas cubanos liderados
por el fotógrafo gabriel guerra
bianchini que han abrazado l net y los
toquen no fungibles para concebir un
tipo social club a lo buena vista que no
consista sólo en la venta de mil 492
retratos digitales sino que cree
comunidad con sus compradores y
desconecte culturalmente con el mundo
[Música]
mientras que el nuevo de 18 años
marcados por la guerra y la invasión de
eeuu
pudo celebrar su primer festival de
música baile y artes babylon
protagonizado en las ruinas de la
antigua ciudad
[Música]
con este retorno cultural decimos un
hasta luego que porta el ritmo de la
amistad entre jorge drexler y c tangana
tras nominado y con tocarte ahora el
madrileño devuelve dúo al uruguayo
cuídense mucho y muchas gracias
pero tiene usted dos cadenas posesión y
presumir de utilizándonos en el balcón y
lo descartes hasta aplicarte y entrar
contigo en brazos la suite el cero hasta
el gentío gallina la bolsa o la vida
aplicar medicina chupar gol o sin perder
la partida de perthus saliva jugarme la
vida buscarme la ruina tocar
[Música]